20 of the biggest generic prescription
drug makers are accused of committing a
multi-billion dollar fraud on people in
the u.s. 43 states and Puerto Rico filed
a complaint friday alleging the company
is coordinated to inflate prices and
reduce competition on more than 100
generic prescription drugs last night on
60 minutes correspondent Bill Whitaker
talked to investigators who say the
evidence is in company emails text and
phone records we can see that competitor
a is talking to competitor B five times
on one day and what that allows us to do
is to go into our document database and
look on that day at what they were
saying it all snapped into sharp focus
when he matched phone logs to thousands
of text messages from heritage
pharmaceuticals Nielsen says this
exchange with competitors citron Pharma
showed collusion to increase the price
of a diabetes medication the text
messages implicate two other companies
Aurobindo and Teva the world's largest
generic drug maker the national accounts
manager at Heritage wrote we are raising
the price right now just letting you
know Tevis says they will follow
Aurobindo agrees to a corporate account
representative from citron answered we
are definitely in to raise pricing are
doing this immediately we reached out to
the Association for accessible medicines
a trade group which represents generic
prescription drug companies those
companies deny engaging in any illegal
collusion in a statement the Association
says it is committed to supporting
policies that promote competition it
also notes prices have declined overall
in the last three years Connecticut
Attorney General William Tong was
featured in the 60 minutes report he is
leading the state's coalition against
the generic drug drug companies good
morning good morning John
so the complaint is 510 pages 34 counts
20 companies 15 individuals that seems
like a pretty broad scope yeah it's what
we believe to be the biggest corporate
cartel in history and probably the
biggest antitrust price-fixing case in
this country
certainly right now and and maybe in our
nation's history you say these companies
are too big to care what do you mean by
that
yeah you said not too big to fail but
too big to care on the air last night
that gave me chills when I heard you
saying yeah and and what's really
troubling is it's clear that they're
just gonna break the law as long as they
can afford to do so you know these are
extraordinarily powerful forces that got
away with price increases as as high as
1,000 mm last night on 60 minutes they
reported that a drug that I take
doxycycline saw a price increase of
eight thousand percent and they've
gotten away with it for such a long time
and that's why it took more than 40
states coming together and taking them
on on behalf of the people of this
cutaway with it you know it's just that
they're so powerful and there's so much
money to be made and nobody has held
them accountable and we took the first
step in 2016 and finally in a case
focused on a company called heritage but
this case now that we filed on Friday is
ten times bigger hundreds of drugs you
know almost 20 of the biggest generic
drug manufacturers 16 individual
corporate defendants we're blowing the
lid off this whole thing because you
know they're really this is an attack on
the American people it's it's a massive
fraud that focuses on the drugs that we
take every day anybody who's on
medication will say gosh the price of
drugs has gone up a lot yeah
or it's affected people in their family
a great deal how did you find out and
discover that there was this alleged
collusion so I really have to hand it to
my Cole and Joe Nielsen in my office you
know they read an article about a drug
called digoxin you know five years ago
and they said something's not right
about a huge price spike that isn't
explainable by the market or market
forces so they started asking questions
but really what blew this whole thing
wide open is are the phone records and
we've gotten I think 11 million phone
records 7 million documents and they
started piecing it together and what
they saw what they saw is is that around
price increases competitors started
calling each other at a very high rate
high-frequency contacts between
competitors sometimes for a minute two
minutes 45 minutes you note ever talking
to Milan talking to Sandoz back and
forth representatives of these companies
having conversations which are highly
illegal when you when you talk about
price-fixing illegal because a market is
supposed to exist without people trade
it whispering behind the scenes supposed
to exist with competition buyers and
sellers right Congress created the
generic drug market so that there would
be competition after patents expire you
would expect competitors to jump into
the giant drug market and and compete
with each other and price should go down
what disturbs you most about all of this
you know what disturbs me most is that
this was undertaken utterly without
shame and it feels like you know it's
just a routine feature of the industry
these folks live in New Jersey Delaware
Pennsylvania not far from this studio
and they go in in the morning and they
break the law and then they go to lunch
and then they go home and they watch TV
and they make dinner and then they get
up in the morning again and they break
the law and it's this this routine every
day admit that really bothers me what's
it the outcome criminal charges people
go to jail what's gonna happen sure you
know I think there's a criminal
investigation being undertaken by the
Department of Justice we have civil
jurisdiction along with our sister
states in 44 other states we had a
previous lawsuit that had 49 states and
territories and we want to hold them
accountable and and as I said last night
on 60 minutes we want to claw back the
money that they stole from the American
people but you know many of the
companies say TEVAR for instance says
they've done nothing wrong the drug
companies say prices go up with drug
shortages and the market forces this
also bothers me we have emails we have
text messages we have cooperating
witnesses we have high-frequency records
of phone calls that happen you know on
the days that price increases happen you
have competitors talking to each other
over and over and over again and then to
look us in the eye and say never happen
we didn't do it nothing wrong
has occurred and we're not fixing prices
or allocating market share amongst each
other it's just not credible
all right Attorney General Tom thank you
so much for being with us